[музика]
добрий день як ви знаєте у зв'язку зі
ситуації, що склалася в країні
коронавірус до вид 19 та карантином
політична партія європейська
солідарність відкрило гарячу лінію
праворуч грамотні змогли звичайно ж
пройти повз тут працюють наші волонтери
вони не медики але ви можете звертатися по
номеру вказаному нижче ми зробили базу
знань все що стосується коронавірусу
симптоматика які ваші дії куди
можна зателефонувати куди можна звернутися
є ще один варіант допомоги вам якщо
раптом ми не знаємо відповіді на запитання
який у вас
ми обіцяємо вам найближчим часом
передзвонити та знайти всі необхідні
відповіді та третій момент якщо раптом ви
хочете бути волонтером чи вам потрібна
фізична допомога
ми самостійно реєструємо заявку на
сайті у 2020 . org.ua
сподіваємося, що найближчим часом вам
допоможуть телефонувати
залишайтеся вдома та мити руки
[музика]